Lo que quiero hacer en este video es cerciorarme
de que fácilmente podemos manejar
expresiones algebraicas que incluyen fracciones.
Empecemos con un ejemplo sencillo, supongamos
que tenemos "a" sobre "b" más "c" sobre "d".
Si queremos sumar estas dos fracciones para
tener una sola fracción, ¿cómo hacemos eso?
Bien, para empezar necesitamos encontrar un
común denominador entre "b" y "d",
no conocemos "b", no conocemos "d", pero sabemos que el producto de "b" por "d" es un múltiplo de ambos.
Así es que podemos escribir esto como dos
fracciones que tienen común denominador
"bd" más algo sobre "bd".
Déjame usar colores para distinguir.
Así es que "a" sobre "b" es lo mismo ¿a qué?
sobre "bd".
Si para obtener "bd" multipliqué el denominador por "d", vamos a multiplicar también el numerador por "d",
de esa manera la expresión no se altera,
pues estamos multiplicándola por "d"sobre "d",
esto va a ser "a" por "d" sobre"b" por "d",
observa que si divido el numerador
y el denominador entre "d", regreso a "a" entre "b".
Y ahora, veamos la segunda fracción, "c" sobre "d".
Para ir de "d" a "bd" multiplicamos por "b",
así que si multipliqué el denominador por "b"
para no alterar el valor de la fracción,
tengo que multiplicar el numerador también por "b",
así es que también el numerador
lo multiplicamos por "b", por lo cual va a ser "bc".
Tenemos entonces, "bc" sobre "bd", que es
lo mismo que "c" sobre "d".
Lo que tengo aquí en magenta, esta fracción,
es equivalente a esta fracción,
simplemente lo multiplique por "d" sobre "d" que es 1,
suponiendo que "d" es distinto de 0.
También aquí hemos multiplicado "c" sobre
"d" por 1, que es lo mismo que "b" sobre "b"
suponiendo que "b" es distinto de 0.
Así que esta fracción y esta fracción,
son equivalentes.
¿Y para qué nos tomamos todas estas molestias?,
bien ahora las fracciones ya tienen un común denominador,  por lo cual ya podemos sumarlas.
Así es que esto es igual a el común denominador
"bd", es el denominador común a ambas fracciones
y ¿qué pasa en el numerador?
Podemos sumar los numeradores como si fueran
simples números,
como si no estuvieran en una fracción,
pues tienen el mismo denominador.
Así es que esto es igual a "ad" más "bc",
todo eso dividido entre "bd".